All right, good evening everyone. We're going to go over some questions that a lot of people have
that I think will be beneficial to everybody. So when we talk about, a lot of people come to us
to begin with because they don't want to be on a ton of supplements and literally we've
had people and maybe you're one of them that brought into us a laundry basket full of supplements
that they're taking. We had one person one time she had 11 grocery bags full to the top of supplements.
That I think was a record. So I don't think that's good for us. I don't think that our
body can handle all that. I don't think that there I think that there could be some dangers of
taking too many things. But that being said, I probably air on giving too little things sometimes
that and I know that a lot of our patients come to us and say is there something that I can add?
Is there anything else I can do and that's what we want to discuss today? Is there anything else
I can add? Is there anything else I could do? I feel like I want to do something else. I read about
this on your blog. I read about this on the internet. Can I add this? So I'm going to go over a few
things that I think are safe that everybody could add if they want to. Of course we want you to feel
like you are led to do something. We don't want you to be making decisions based upon fear. We don't
think that you should just be adding stuff all the time. And again, we don't want you to take too
many things. But there are some things that are probably safe for everybody to add and some of them
are tend to be my favorite. So a few of my favorite natural chemotherapies is what we're going to call
this. So that being said, that's the first one is one of my favorite is medicinal mushrooms. So
the medicinal mushrooms are beneficial because so many people over the years that we've been using
them have tested out that this is the thing that is going to be the made natural chemotherapy for
their cancer. That'd be incentive. You're like, well, I didn't get told to take those. Is it
something that a person could add if they so desire? Yes, because there are immune, they are just
immune stimulators. The polysaccharides and mushrooms are stimulate your T cells, stimulate your
age, your macrophages to help stimulate an attack on cancer cells. So it is something if you do
want to add, there's something to add. Now, there's people that come to us with capsilized different
types of mushrooms that we have on their different types of mushrooms that are capsilized and so
created to be sold retail. The ones that we use, we blend ourselves. They're a blend of
eight or ten different, not just mushrooms, other immune stimulants. On our website, on our store,
you can see the ingredients that are in them. It's a powdered form, comes in a jar or a bag if we're
shipping it to you, just like this. And we typically tell people take one to three teaspoons
a day of that mixed into their smoothie. It does have a mushroom-y kind of earthy type flavor,
not necessarily super tasty. You can mix that with just hot water, make a tea out of it, and add
a peppermint tea bag to it too. I take this, not on a daily basis, but I do take this on a fairly
regular basis along with our chaga mushroom blend, which is just straight chaga, which is another
kind of mushroom. So it's one of my favorites. It's a great immune stimulator, and this is something
that everybody could really take. So next one is the aloe, or aloe, however you want to
pronounce it, product that we use. This works on the same basis of mushrooms. It's the polysaccharides
that are in mushrooms and in aloe that actually work as an immune stimulator to stimulate T cells,
to stimulate macrophages, to stimulate an attack on cancer cells and on bacteria, on viruses. These
are things both the mushrooms and the aloe here you could take just if you don't have cancer,
you just want to boost your immune system or you're fighting a virus or a bacteria, you're just trying
to stay healthy. These are things that you could take as well. Now this aloe is very unique because
it is patented. It is processed in a way that it's very specific polysaccharide chains that have been
found to stimulate T cells and macrophages the best. So this would be actually a step above the
mushrooms in a sense. The reason why I like our mushroom blend is that it's multiple different
types of mushrooms. So it has that synergistic effect because of the different things that are
in there. This is just the immune stimulants from that polysaccharides from aloe. This is one of the
things that I think has really helped me a lot and in my dealing with cancer. So I take this
everyday without fail. So this is a big product for me. B17 is also a product that people are
questioned about a lot because you hear a lot about lateral. This is something that wasn't legal
to find anywhere in the United States up until a few years ago when the laws were relaxed out
of this because nobody dies from it. Nobody gets hurt from it. There are any rear side effects from
it. Just like anything else, if you took the whole model of it, you probably ended up with stomach ache,
but that's not regardless. B17 can be a good cancer killer. I do not use this. It tests out on a
percentage of people that we use and we recommend it is we do find a lot of patients come to us that are
already wanting to take B17. They've been reading about it. I think it's something that everybody
could add if they want to. It's not going to be something that's going to really bogged out your liver.
So that's something to add and I would say this is the we have the 100 milligrams and the 500 milligrams. Sorry,
this picture is a little buggy. This is the 500 milligram picture here. If you're going to get the 500
milligram, you probably just start with one a day and 100 milligram, you might only start with one that's
three a day as well. But this is something else that people could add if they want to.
SCAC is another big name cancer killer that's out there that people want to add. SCAC is an
herbal blend and the herbs in it are also really good for your liver. So we have patients that do not
have cancer that take SCAC just because it's a liver tautic. You can take it straight right out of
this bottle. There are some other powdered SCACs that you can you make your own tea out of. They're
good products too. This is the original SCAC blend that we're using here and it is already mixed. So
you would just take a teaspoon to a tablespoon of this, put it in the glass, add some hot water,
let it steep itself even though it's already liquid form and you sip it over the course of 30 minutes.
That's how the technical way how you're supposed to take SCAC, how the Ojibwe Indians taught her
day KSC how to take SCAC and that's how she told her cancer patients to take SCAC. We have had some
people just put it in a smoothie. It is just an herbal blend or take it with other supplements. I don't
think there's any big harm at taking it any way like that too. The story of SCAC is on our website
because it's a really interesting story. It's a great herbal blend and we have these on our store
as well. So there's so many other ones. So curcumin is a big one that we recommend for just about
everybody though there's so many research articles probably more than any other nutrient are there
research articles on curcumin that we have to include it. It's just so beneficial. It's a
most people use curcumin as an anti-inflammatory but they don't realize the amount of research articles
that are out on curcumin that are based on basically it's cancer killing or it's cancer blocking
benefits. It blocks so many cancer pathways and it helps stimulate apoptosis in cancer cells
that it's crazy. It's just a great product. So we have multiple curcumin products. We have a new
powder that's a fermented powder product that we just got in. Still the best as far as absorbability
usability is this curcuclear. It's the C3 curcumin. So this is just really a great product. The
Uncle Bell Pro is a Rualphea product. I just posted some new blog posts on that. I recommend you look
that up too. That's a great product for certain types of cancer. The research is for
pay grant a cancer. It'll vary a cancer but it's not that it will work on many different cancers.
Hoxy protocell. There's just so many really good cancer killing products out there. I wouldn't
necessarily throw protocell even though I mentioned it in this little video here but I wouldn't
necessarily throw that in there that everybody should add that or everybody could add that.
The Rualphea everybody could add. Hoxy everybody could add. Curcumin everybody probably should add.
If you're taking sunscreen, know that you're getting about a gram of curcumin today because there's
the C3 curcumin in the sun spectrum. So if you're not taking the curcuclear, don't go a little crazy
on me here but you are getting at the sun spectrum. Curcuclear is a good thing to add as an anti-inflammatory
anti-pean thing as well. All right, so now we are going to open it up for questions and if you have
any please speak up. I have one. I've had the genetic review at the clinic of course and
if I what is what in the genetic test will what's gene group tells whether one is
more susceptible to fungal, fungal exposure or less susceptible to fungal exposure.
Whether you're going to have more issues if you have fungal exposure. Yes, is there a genetic group
that just specifically deals with the fungal? Not really. There is. There's been
we've been involved in three different studies on Lyme disease which that's not fungal. That's
going to be more bacteria and the co-infection. Some viral co-infections involved are there not
really a big fungal category of co-infections. I would think that if I would think that it could
correspond with that correlation, those that have more issues with chronic Lyme, there's probably
about 20 different genes that are more common for people with chronic Lyme to have defects on
than those that don't have chronic Lyme. So you could possibly equate that and I could have who did
your genetic review? Was it hand or Ashley? And it. So I could have had call you and kind of go over
those with you if that will help. And then the mold? Yeah, so I think that would fall into that same
category. Okay. That would be great, Dr. Palmer. Okay. Anything else? So on those favorite natural chemotherapies
mushrooms that the first one you mentioned about the mushrooms, I know some of the products I'm
taking already have that in it. Yep, so we don't want you taking too many things. So if you're
already taking those things in a different product, then just keep doing that. Okay, thank you.
Donna, you had a question? Yes, I did. A couple weeks ago, you and I had talked about
the extreme pain that I've been having in my legs and do you recommend that I increase my
chocu clear? Because I'm also taking sunscreen on top of that, I take three curcuclear.
And you said I should be taking more. How much more should I be taking?
Well, if you're taking a scoop of the sunscreen a day, you're getting about a grab of
curcumid. If you're taking three of the curcuclear, you're getting equivalent to about four grams a
day. You could go up to eight to nine grams a day. Okay. So I would tight-trade up a little bit
and see what makes a difference. You do have to get the tissue saturated, so you have to give it a
few days of taking that dosage to see what the, oh, it makes a difference. Okay, all right.
By order, someone's just waiting for it to come in. Okay. Yeah, we had it on back order.
We just got a bunch in though, so. Okay, very good. All right. Thank you so much.
Yes, I would recommend I did post it on Facebook today too, that you don't forget about our blogs.
On the resources page of the website, I am literally writing anywhere between three and seven new
blog posts a week. So most of them are on cancer. Even if they're not on cancer, they would be
interesting to read. I try to shorten up the research and make it appropriate information
to make it usable and beneficial knowledge for people. So make sure you peek at those. I think those
are helpful too. Yeah. All right. So make sure also I keep forgetting to remind you, if you do have
questions that you want to get answered or you want me to address more of a little video format like
this, email those in because that's what sparked this little video. Somebody emailed a question
about other things that they could add. So email those questions in and just put it in the subject
line, just put zoom questions. So I can search it and get out of that. All right. You guys have a
wonderful evening. John, do you have another question? I do. What was it that that Donna the issue was
about pain that you asked you told us? Yeah. So she had, she's having some some pain. And I said,
what are the ways that you could deal with it from a natural perspective is to increase the
curcumin. So we get down to that slide. We talk about the curcuclear, increasing the dosage of
that. You know, if you're just taking that as your source of curcumin, you could go up to eight to
died of these a day to help decrease pain. Okay. Thank you. All right. All right. Well, thank you
guys for being on and we will talk to you next week. All right. I was just wondering how your
your cancer journey was going and how we can pray more effectively for you since we pray for you
every day. Well, thank you. Thank you. Continue to pray for healing. Pray for wisdom and
pray for that. Stay focused on it. Be fulfilling my purpose, which is doing everything I can to help
you. So what keeps me going is to keep focused on that. I was interviewed by some of some
gal who's doing a longevity seminar. And I'm a guest on that that's going to air this fall or
something like that. Yeah, it's one of her. Her last questions are was something about what's the best
piece of advice you can tell people to keep going. And boy, she didn't tell me she was going to ask that
question. So I just, well, I guess best piece of advice is to wake up every day and ask God, who could
you help today? So that's what I want to remember to do. I don't always do that. So I want to remember
to do that every day because that's what keeps me moving forward and ignoring my pain and keep
pushing through it. So. That's right. God's got a purpose at all of this, right? He does. Praise his name.
Amen. All right. Thanks you guys. Thank you. Have a blessed afternoon.
All right. We'll see you in a couple of weeks. All right. Thank you.